myriam leroux de chez elle a une vue
complète dégagé sur le terrain qui
devrait accueillir le projet une
station-service et des nuisances sonores
environnementale de fréquentation
de sécurité on va dire sécurité en
toujours par rapport à nos enfants ça
c'est ça a été la plus grosse inquiétude
c'est qu'il ya des études qui montrent
que la présence de stations service et
les émanations de gaz sont très
dangereuses pour les enfants
d'autres habitants du quartier de wall
street et qui pensait couler des jours
paisibles ont eux aussi ce projet en
travers de la gorge
nos maisons qui sont à proximité n'ont
aucune valeur à bien le domaine ont
aucune valeur qui va accepter de venir
devenir soit loué ou acheté ces maisons
qui se trouvent à proximité depuis
depuis de nuisance personnes donc nous
nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
demandeurs au niveau de notre
tranquillité et au niveau financier
aussi pour le maire du vauclin il s'agit
d'une agitation de l'opposition à la
veille des échéances électorales
d'autant plus que le dossier obtenu
toutes les autorisations administratives
nécessaires
citons jeune marin pêcheur au chômage
qui s'est reconverti après avoir subi de
graves dommages à des tempêtes et qu'il
sera volatile le commerce et il a monté
un dossier avec l'aide de bureaux
spécialisés pour une station d'essence
en zone rurale comme ça glisse avait pas
rentrer martinique et toutes les
administrations publiques ont mis un
avis favorable
donc j'ai donc signé le permis
elle ne peut pas faire différemment de
ceux ci je n'ai pas signé
elop m'attaquez devant un tribunal les
lots à gagner le collectif a décidé
d'introduire un recours en annulation
auprès du tribunal administratif
une affaire à suivre